all right gorgeous welcome back thanks
so Rebecca how are things hmm what's
going on a bitter long day you you're
the last couple of times you've been
here you were upbeat and very perky
today you're a little bit yeah I'm just
I've been sleeping all night I don't
usually sleep too much so yeah so you're
short on sleep right now no like too
much sleep Oh too much sleep yeah and I
mean so your typical day uh uh drug uses
what how how big is drug use in your day
it's not imperative but it's there yeah
yeah so you typically you'll wake up and
you'll do what I've got I run around
your debt your I just I keep to myself
honestly really yeah and nobody nobody
bothers you mm-hmm yeah I mean sometimes
you know I mean it happened I have never
never seen you with black eyes or
bruised up or any like that mmm
do you have a goal for your set for
yourself where you like to be in a
couple years or something that I can you
told you that I don't know I don't know
I forget some of our conversation I have
so many conversations I forget them I
say there's my gettin to the fashion
industry I just really oh that's right
we did talk about me did you have any
romantic interests in your life no I
know ya know there is someone but I know
what does he look like
I don't want to talk about it you don't
talk about
what do you want to talk about anything
no no no you go ahead
I don't really have anything to say
today what happened today you get to
press sometimes sometimes do you I mean
would you consider yourself someone who
has like you know depression that's the
magazine or I'd say it's just a polarity
just bipolar start oh yeah
you go the mission sometimes to eat hmm
not really where do you eat I know I
just kind of like I find food like I
dumpster dives and stuff did you yeah
and eating out of a dumpster is okay for
you I mean as long as like you know what
I mean like I never they go out and take
like I'm very Fortran haven't gotten
sick I mean the lack of responsibility
that this lifestyle has is that is that
appealing to you is it I would suppose
so it's not about responsibility as much
as and stuff recklessness I don't know
like it's a better way to get to
understand yourself or kind of be of
your own rather than which and or they
call it like kind of a modality or a
pattern
is there something attractive I mean you
told me you'd love skid-row before is
there's something about the freedom or
the or the I think there's more of an
energy you know what I mean like there's
I'm able to have like there's there's
room for self-expression without like I
don't necessarily need to interact I
just like i10 like I prefer to keep to
myself lately
I just wonder if there's a psych
medication or something that you're not
taking that might help you stabilize and
maybe help you not really no but you
know doctor what's the nicest thing
that's happened to you lately probably
just being on myself
what do you miss about your old life
what do you hope for mmm
just to keep kind of the pace that I'm
honored to kind of keep practicing I'm
practicing a kind of existing how
existing
and family is not part of your life any
longer it isn't it isn't it said like
it's a presence but at the same time
like family is really important to me
though my time they are really important
they are ya know I love my family you
love your family yeah do you ever have
contact with them sometimes some I know
I'm kind of doing what I'm doing right
now yeah that's that's clear is your
family concern for you don't you think
so all right are you concerned for you
yes and no like I like the pace that I'm
at like I like this self-sustainability
but at the same time like I'm trying to
find ways to evolve yeah I mean III
think a lot of my viewers have see so
much potential in you like every time
you come by you're just like oh there's
there's my friend Rebecca I would love
to see her just get her [ __ ] together
and just I see so much potential but
that's what I want to do your
personality is so much that's what I
want to do it's just a matter of how to
communicate it or how to communicate
what it is that I'm moving because I
think there's so much what I'm doing
that's not as understood or it's maybe
because it's coming from a softer it's
coming from a place like the way that I
practice or the way that I exist it's
not as immediately perceivable but at
the end of the day like I know how I'm
going about it because I'm coming from a
place of awareness or maybe attempting
to instigate something new you know what
I mean rather than rely on an outdated
modem or an outdated understanding of
how to exist
oh I mean there's been many many people
I've interviewed and I would love to see
a stable clear-headed version of down
the road I would just love to see what
you're like with your life together
maybe like with a little responsibility
a little like you know discipline and
like a little bit of like a life and
solidity in your life okay I'm very
interesting to see who you who you are
then they're just are just more
continuity I guess or something
something yeah just a bit like not
stability but like something like
reliability is yeah I'm gonna I'm
repeating myself I just see so much
potential in you and it's like it just
seems like it's wasted here on Skid Row
I would think that I feel that I wasn't
that I don't I don't you're a very
interesting person
thank you and you're beautiful I think
your your your face and just your energy
and your your personality are so
likeable I think I just hook you you get
it together somehow I don't know what
that is I don't even know I don't even
know I've no idea I'm not sure you you
know yeah all right well I'm gonna give
you some lunch money and I can't wait to
see what you're wearing next time I see
you
yeah I've said to stop by anytime Thanks
I love you Thanks
okay we're back are you back I love what
you're wearing today thank you
where'd you find that I just found it on
the floor you just found it somewhere
yeah
the garment district is right near
exceed Rosa yeah you find stuff like
this sometimes um are you in a better
mood today kind of kind of still cut it
down yeah what's going on like up and
down I don't know um it's like I feel
like something really good it's gonna
happen to me but like something that
I've been waiting for almost it's cool
yeah it's nice to have that feeling yeah
let's go all right what's on your wrist
or your hospital yeah I was in the
hospital before I was I was feeling kind
of suicide also oh no yeah yeah
sometimes and then what do they give you
for that um they didn't give me anything
it's just kind of this place Exodus like
you can just kind of go and relax right
yeah Exodus yeah taking Amanda over
there yeah what uh so what gets you out
of a Down mood like that
I don't know usually you know just
finding yeah just time and sometimes
sleep helps right yeah no I've been that
cuz I've been sleeping a lot lately
usually like when I sleep it just kind
of like messes with me so I'm just kind
of ready to get back up and so you feel
like more positive right now yeah good
yeah that's great
like it like it was a better morning
than I would have presumed it to be good
yeah well I hope you have a great rest
of the day and week and whatever good
thing you're having a premonition about
it's great yeah
all right be careful out there oh well
yeah all right Becca thanks I
you